yeah what coming to this video playing
Kelly on Carlo de mujer from from Italy
very strong blitz player is always I
don't know flip-flopping between 2302
and 25 or so is um quite quite good at
blitz ah come on I know it's down but
the the usual sloth I simply don't have
any good stuff let's see what he's doing
the a6 line and what needs to make sure
that you don't make it so easy for black
we succeed factor some as a mistake
brooksy a test some more precise no I'm
blackest black Kison and slide trouble
yeah yeah the problem is he needs to UM
have a blender correctly he needs to
play knight c6 back now and then 95 is
some really a problem b5 i can sacrifice
might be five I think
yeah this is should I think 95 as well
on b5 I can always sacrifice I think not
be five
on the CF 96 this kind of sick move 9
p-5 a baby should be 596
p 5 85 / shall be 596 mmm i can play
night so they can play night xc60 rook
takes a 498 or what a sick line okay I
need to do this anyway to be honest
cannot no no it's too too late for for
any turning bag of course so now this
move
rook takes a four-night 68
hmm yeah I always feel a bit stupid and
it's this is just lost this this line
that he played but i'm not sure if this
is really the refutation and it's not so
easy to calculate it correctly in blitz
always a bit frustrating if you know
okay i should win now but um you forget
how it is done and to calculate it on
your own in little time as it's always a
different issue but it should be you
should be ok ok so where I where to go
now kingi to that should be correct to
connect rocks the moment does that two
pieces hanging but I have 96 as a
possibility so okay the question is is
what about rook c8 is this good now
looxcie 896 mages the threat
maybe you can cancel short or some
signal so it's possible or just 96 with
the idea to play 95 they're probably I
have a tactical when am I look c7 work
c7 is also not bad okay i hope that this
this is enough 96 mate it's not not one
of those little threats and turn the
move like kinky 796 check out that winds
through the house rupee to check king of
three and he's got only got one
additional check yeah this is a
possibility em I can now grab this and
hope that I keep all my pieces but I
don't think he can he can catch them 96
or so coming
maybe some strange move be sure before
so threatening Ruby to end the King
where's my king going those little thing
things can be a problem here all this
King t3 and then Eve or maybe
yeah I rugby to a rock d to medium this
is this is the problem should be too
muah
look see two at the enter the didn't
notice is falling to t1 is covered need
to do that
yeah so storm in practical game at squad
Rakim
check
here probably check late that is a mate
yeah yeah I don't tell ya this is one of
those moments where I better don't say
anything because it's uh it's really
pointless just need to be bit more
precise and black just resins but it's
it's still tricky this is actually lost
already according to the computer you
found the only winning line with Bishop
e2 Bishop asics winning now the
computers I wants to go f3 add this is
already tricky so what's their cleaner
win even since maybe maybe there is a
cleaner one
Jack yeah maybe King terminal King to d1
is better now Rosie 8 looks normal oh
it's winning piece ok I mean this is
this is a win what can you say but it's
it's easy to go wrong and blitz
obviously have three yeah this is
probably what I should play
well I was afraid of this move computer
gives this yeah but this is some not the
door easy with no time on the clock
dad's always Ted frustrating because its
own it's pretty pretty well known that
you six is just a bad mistake because of
queen bee three and now black has got
them got some trouble already okay but
the reputation is obviously as we have
seen not so so easy to to prove over the
board our Bishop takes b5 a stronger
here this is good to know this is a
flat-out win okay okay yeah this is of
course a very strong thread and also 97
on this yeah there's this check yeah
okay the best move according to the comp
as this one just completely nonsensical
I just take it cancels at this that's
not no compensation out two points and
okay there's a lost line but the way
edge i plated them it's obviously too
tricky yeah thanks for watching
interesting game